[Music]
in the favela Robin Hood what the hell
is that
it's the Brazil slums ones okay have you
seen City of God really great movie by
the way you should watch it it's awesome
you know that is about child gang
members in the poverty-stricken area
favelas of Brazil sounds lovely
it's romantic I've heard it's good those
cities got this really really good
so goodbye everybody clap your hands oh
it's a shuffle one cupid shuffle is it
like I think it's that one yeah I forgot
I don't even know I don't like those
stupid songs you just did it I think it
was that I don't know I feel like it's
like the thing is like I can't hear you
yeah what would I be saying oh dude I
just be like hey please clap if you
don't want to clap that's chill a
Brazilian drug dealer kidnap medical
staff and made them vaccinate his
community that's some public force
that's really sad oh what key kidnapped
them yeah I know but I mean like that's
what he needed so badly like he needed
medical help so badly he had to turn to
crime and force community though it's
for all the little kids that's like that
movie John Q when Denzel Washington had
a gun on that member hear that gun on
the doctors head while they're gonna
operate understand it's so sad to be
like that much of a dick as a doctor
that you won't do it unless this guns in
your head oh yeah it's like if you lower
the gun he's like oh I'm gonna stop
operating now like I'm not gonna save
them anymore yeah yeah yeah so this guy
he's known as 2n he's considered one of
the most dangerous criminals in Rio de
Janeiro does he have a nice booty 2n
yeah wait what is that
really nice booties you see you some so
he could be a very dangerous criminal
but you also be wearing daisy dukes no
we're too religious is that true
religions are great for me he has a big
butt - I never seen the Daisy Doo you've
seen him in DC
Uncle Sam only where's Daisy dudes there
you go if you guys know Uncle Sam yeah
so for munch Brazil has been dealing
with his yellow fever epidemic and so oh
I thought they just like agents agents a
problem they're dealing with it yeah
yeah trying to fix I never knew that so
focused on getting the info right but
that just went right over my head I was
like you're doing your job don't like
how the Medical Association's like why
do we have to call it yellow fever was
having me in jail do Joe we call it
something else maybe they need to have a
jungle fever to balance it out dirty out
Jonathan everyone's part black over
there
yeah Brazil do you have you ever heard a
[ __ ] Brazil like any game where is it
they have plantains there it's freaking
delicious in America affect the
Portuguese version of Hawaii everyone's
part black everyone's part Portuguese
and there's a ton of Asian and other
white species [ __ ] mixed into it they
have the second most population of
Japanese you are blowing his mind right
now Hawaii and Brazil actually they're
like rivals because they feel like
they're so similar I never heard of
Hawaiian jujitsu today that you've heard
of Brazilian it's called time horse
who doesn't know BJJ at Coors good for
you you never wondered where Brazil vote
was I was it's fine I like Brazil so
what about yellow fever so yellow fever
right it's been in Brazil and so the
Health Ministry plans to vaccinate most
of the population they've been just
focusing on the areas where they have
more money so a lot of the poor areas
like the favelas they've just been
ignored
so 2n took things into his own hands and
he kidnapped two male nurses and just
grabbed as many supplies that they could
in the hospital where they picked him up
and then took them over to his village
or his Ravello and had them vaccinated
everyone dude he created mad loyalty now
all [ __ ] up is the country when the
criminal has to do the good thing did he
return them great story a really hard
dude he's very wanted so wanted for
saving people well for other crying oh
yeah so they're just saying like oh yeah
the police is saying that if anyone has
tips that could lead to Israel no
there's nobody gonna narc on him I got
[ __ ] vaccinated cuz it's nice genius
man yeah
ain't no one turning his ass in yeah
that's what Escobar did yeah yeah he
would take care of the people not that
he wasn't a [ __ ] [ __ ] obviously
but I'm saying that that's what he did
win him over to win him over I'm painted
elementary-school than [ __ ] yeah
completely remodelled them they're
calling him like the Robin Hood of
thoughts or is he securing his customers
for life because if all of his customers
die no one's gonna buy his product imma
soon as a drug dealer but if he looks
like hey all my customers about to die
but if I keep them alive and they can
continuously buy my product is he a drug
dealer so maybe there's ulterior motive
they just say that he's just one of the
most dangerous criminals oh oh what's
all dangerous about it was a booty
bangin is it - in the letter n the
number two
and the letter n yeah what does that
stand for no one ever knows maybe he
borrowed from 2 Chainz
the real question is I love always know
that photo again the real question is
what kind of a [ __ ] melted ass
Mountain Dew is that yeah what is this
that's all melted as Mountain Dew cab
that's gonna call or send [ __ ] that's
from Brazil not anything
somewhere down there I like how you get
the crushed peanuts things and you
sprinkle that [ __ ] all over the collard
greens oh we got to get some Brazilian
barbecue
can I ask a man question please how do
guys get the line for their mustache so
thin and precise like what are they use
they use that little uh Sh it's a little
trimmer thing yeah the trimmer one oh
really
yeah it looks like a dildo Oakley's it's
like a tiny bilbo dildo yeah sure it's
like like that like this thing I've
always wondered like what should I think
you know those big-ass norelco things
with like five heads I don't look like
this
Oh usually on the back there's a
depressing tiny little trimmer you know
you find your sisters you find your
sisters like like vibrator yep
you know I mean it's like that but I
don't know those half mustaches yeah why
do you and they just have it just right
over the lip it looks like a [ __ ]
eyebrow it's like a poo Manchus
accentuates the mouth oh god it's like
the mr. Miyagi thing I have one that
goes under the lip and then you
purposely safe draw it in no Pat Morita
had a real thin Pat Maria kept too soon
that's true yeah just put like eyebrow
yeah I mean I I feel like my brows I
could fill in your mustache for you oh
you want it to connect to the gross I
think it's kind of cool cos like a
curtain and an underneath there's like a
lie extra drapes yeah it's great what we
think looks cool it's like this
that's do you think his thing looks cool
no I just love that what we think looks
cool oh you mean but like we probably do
you think it also looks cool on other
guys or you like you know I think it
always looks cooler on other guys and I
can't usually do it that's what you're
saying I'm saying that uh he's jealous
of black guys and then Asian guys
because they can wear the coolest stuff
if I wore anything cool he would keep
that place Ryan where's the coolest
[ __ ] jackets
he wears cool shoes you guys were cool
shoes Ryan why not write the one that
you work with all the time you don't
even know his name
no one ever talks about Ryan so the
crews jackal
he wears the coolest [ __ ] sickest
jackets I can't wear any of that [ __ ] I
have to wear like I think you could you
don't have to wear an accounting
managers job I know that's like Nicky
wanted to marry you but yeah you're in
you got her so now you can like you
don't have to look like you can cut
loose you can cut look at you can wear
the hats like this way no I can't I look
straight up look like I'm about to suck
a dick I just do I just have one of
those faces
I have a punchable face so when you add
like a side cat it looks like I'm about
to take on it believe you I believe for
sure maybe not hats but we'll start with
jackets okay maybe shoes and then we can
use I would love to hear were some cool
shoes you can know they're cool no these
are alarming what size shoe do I buy a
pair shoes oh yeah I work 13 and what
month is your birthday it's August okay
that's a while from now a long time I
don't know
August 27th you should start a Pinterest
of all the things that you do want to
wear I actually mean this - it's not
even stick look I do we yeah right now
Niki Niki has been coming down on my ass
lately because I where I were not great
I we're not great clothes pretty
regularly like I dressed up for you guys
you look great well thank you um no Niki
has no input on my wardrobe but she's
about to fix that because it's getting
pretty nuts like you guys know I wear
wu-tang's shirts and like I [ __ ]
don't care but well thank you alchemy is
not cool shoes another I was raising my
mom was always like you know like you
don't need to flash you need to flash so
I don't do that girlfriend until the
flash for you we flash in different ways
funny shirts yes yeah Mike that's my
rule is I if I that's all I've worn so
far is if a shirt makes me laugh I have
to buy it yeah like that's what I have
with myself
so the NFL Network made you like bust up
no this was a gift from a buddy of mine
and I lost all my hoodies like all my
hoodies are like covered in cat hair so
I had to grab this today
covered in cat hair but nobody gave this
to me when he met Marshall Faulk which
is pretty cool and he gave me a sign
Marshall for football that's why he's a
cult legend so it's pretty cool man
top story well you got to keep that then
yeah even if it makes you look like a
dad I know it does yeah it looks like
I'm gonna take my kids to Disney World
today
[Laughter]
[Music]